can you imagine getting in a quad
accident you go
[Laughter]
[Music]
so uh there was a father of three who
had a kind of tragic accident on a quad
bike while riding along a beach in
Argentina uh and went missing for some
time what
it's so funny because I just imagined
they saw the guy on the bike it crashes
and then they're like where the [__] did
he go
well what happened is he he was kind of
off-roading along this stretch of the
coastline and then uh I guess allegedly
fell in that accident off the coastline
so it was gone for a while his wife you
know what you do at the beach you look
for the footprints in the sand and it's
usually
you know it might have been a cliff
[Laughter]
um no it goes into a different direction
yeah he disappears his wife Virginia
posted a bunch of like desperate
messages on Facebook and stuff trying to
like get in touch and see if anybody
found him two days later his damaged
all-terrain vehicle and helmet were
found on a beach uh near this area rokus
Colorado a protected area of lagoons
dunes and colored rock formations
um and then that weekend two local men
went fishing and hauled in three sharks
out of the sea oh cool and inside the
shark's belly was the man they cut the
shark open to clean them and prepare
them for eating they found human remains
yo all these human remains there was a
tattoo still that you could see
depicting a rose which was still visible
on the arm of the body which matched the
tattoo that this dude Mr Barrio had
allowing for him to be identified can
you imagine getting in a quad accident
you go
[Laughter]
you survived follow [__] wave because oh
[__] with a drown you like survived
the wave
I know
not not everywhere has sharks yeah yeah
if I had to judge this scenario I think
God really wanted him dead yeah yep yeah
and I'll make you a Christian right
because he fell off the bike the wave
pulled them in then it's like he was
trying to survive but God's like uh just
make it easy it's really hard to not see
the will of the Lord in this hand the
will of the Lord sometimes people say
Jesus is a better assassin than the CIA
agent people say that yeah
speaking of one of the uh the comments
on his article one of like the most like
liked comments on the article did
mention like what are the chances that
like you get eaten by a shark and that
shark is also caught yeah you know what
I mean in that same week where your
remains have not been digested so that
you can still close and get closure bro
yeah you know what I mean that crazy
level also says God will never give you
a tribulation too much for you to handle
so what happened here
you are [__] me up right now man the
will of the Lord is destroying me what
do you think about the will of the Lord
this is what you find on the front page
of Yahoo news yeah the work of our
heavenly father hey JK News is here to
report the news you've been following
for a while you know we're we're the
only incredible news source out there I
would say we're the only news stories
out there that doesn't have an agenda
and always hurts ourselves
and we post the stories like it might be
because we don't have an agenda that we
hurt ourselves yeah and we're the only
news that reports other people's news
then we give our own opinions on it it
is interesting proximity to the the fact
that you crash on an ATV roll off a
cliff into the water you think he was
dead before he hit the water I mean how
did were the sharks that close to the
shore or did he wash out you probably
got washed out so he's probably dead in
the water I've been dead
dude nope they want fresh meat baby he
probably fell and when he was going down
the cliff he was breaking his arm
ripping this [__] and when he got into
the water the blood oh yeah I didn't
this charge went what the [__] is that
that's blood yeah and I heard that
sharks don't like eating humans but in
this case they must have been very
hungry
when you smell the blood in the water is
that what they say yeah because humans
taste yucky today is that what they'd
say but they don't have taste buds so I
[__] don't know man they don't have
taste buds I think they just swallow
their [__] food don't they yeah they
just take a bite and just swallow it if
they have a whole arm with a tattoo
still on it well a lot of shark bites
happen because they bite you yeah and
they go oh what the hell but it just so
happens that they have a thousand
[__] teeth so when they bite you just
to test you dead bro but they don't chew
like they don't got molars right yeah
yeah just like [__] regular fish when
you see them eat they're not chewing
they swallow they take one bite and
that's it yeah they're using the suction
force of water that goes out their gills
and suddenly you're fully in there with
the tattoos and all dude that really
sucks man are you religious how did you
grow up religious no no rest in peace
but yeah
Jesus
recipes oh yeah I feel bad
good cheese
that's hard they say they said it is
probable that Miss sabaria had an
accident and was dragged out to sea
um and then they say a strong title
surge could have pulled them in and then
of course that's where the Sharks happen
but I mean do they find the ATV though
yeah they did that's how they knew
that's kind of a good way to kill
somebody though just kill him and dump
them out into sea this is one of those
things that happened on like 1000 Ways
to Die oh yeah yeah yeah it's just so
improbable that it's like it's like
number three it's like really high up
like oh yeah so someone someone needs to
animate this anybody got like a oh good
I was gonna say if his wife is a true
Latina doing they interviewed her she's
like
that [__]
[Laughter]
she's just pushing at his grave look
where it got you
they're at the [__] at the eulogy
Rest In Pieces When I close my eyes
that's a ladder [__] sharks
I do matches and [__] what the [__] is
this
you should have been at home should have
been home with our kids
I [__] know you stupid
[Laughter]
what else happened to this guy man he's
like probably the ATV crash because he
got hit by lightning oh [__] yeah
stunned him so he couldn't swim this
dude was like one in a million in a row
and he tumbled down the cliff hit like
18 cactuses and stuff like that dude
this guy had a Wiley Coyote death that's
[__] up have you guys had like an
incident where it was like this is like
a one in a million type of thing that
like consecutive things happen bro I
thought it was really funny when I
smacked David's face with a surfboard
oh but I felt bad but not that was like
consecutive
this is like anybody got like a one in a
million game I thought it was funny when
I smacked him on the surface but
honestly David is that guy no but that
was though no because like Bart were you
surfing with me I was surfing with you
in the water like and then I was coming
out because you saw a turtle or
something right yeah yeah so a lot going
on right there I was riding David David
was standing and he was like in in knee
deep water right and he was like filming
and he goes this is [__] amazing I
think it's filming you yeah he was
filming us and it was [__] amazing
right and all I remember is slipping
slow motion and the board goes and flies
toward and I see Bart's eyes and he's
like this but he's also going oh it's a
turtle like that right and while Barb's
looking at this Turtle I see this
[__] board fly right into David and
David's just standing there with this
[__] camera like this and I dive into
the water and I get back up and his
[__] face has blood oh no that's
David dude all these accidents they
always [__] happen so we're here in
Hawaii like you're you're one of your
number one things is to try to see a
turtle like swim around right because
you know they exist but they're rare so
you really want to see one so anytime
anyone points that Turtle everyone looks
and I remember Joe was going he gets off
the board it flies directly at David at
the same time I think I see a turtle oh
[__] Turtle so David get gets hit in the
mouth blood gushes everywhere you see
him go like this but he still wants to
see the turtle so he gets up
[Laughter]
damn I didn't know his Priority One it
is for sure everyone's trying to it was
like watching a bullet go toward my
friend and I couldn't do anything about
it
it goes faster you know when you fall
off a skateboard or something yeah
you were wearing a leash yeah
no I don't think so it was launching
though
[__] poor David dude I wouldn't say
there's one in a million but I will say
that felt like 100 million because I was
really drunk
um we were uh celebrating Chad uh not
really bachelor party because his
bachelor party was really epic but uh
just like at our old studio and we all
got drunk and we had a basketball rim
like inside the complex and everybody's
shooting balls and stuff like that and
just celebrating him about to get
married and he had a family wedding
coming up it's a family wedding nobody
else is invited right
um but
he likes to gamble I know he likes to
gamble so I was like hey if I make this
half court shot right now you have to
take him to your family wedding so he's
like that and I was drunk as [__] so he
also made it back because he knew I
wasn't gonna make it I just threw it and
I made it and he has to be mad at work
so he called his uh his wife at the time
Jolie and he's like he's like hey uh we
have to add Anthony and Nina to our
family wedding and I went in the
Philippines no no the family wedding is
here it was during covet to like you
know like they had like really
segregated types of weddings and I was
literally the only dude that was like at
the family wedding because is that
awkward for you or not for me easy I
could just park and eat like I'm super
cool with his cousins I got really cool
this cousins they were smoking me out it
was great
so but hey I suck at basketball so it
felt like one in a nine that's the most
important thing with your hype you suck
at basketball I doubt that too man don't
shame me like that dude you're
gaslighting me no way
you know those minutes like I haven't
even minutes but that
it's like less than a 10 second moment
of realizing you can't do anything but
like you're falling from like an
accident those always feel like an hour
yeah it feels like it takes a long time
because the last time I got into like a
major crash was um I was mountain biking
and as I was coming down I couldn't turn
fast enough so I just [__] hit a
fence and it was one of those wood
fences where there's two and then
there's a pike right so I hit the top
part and then I tumble forward and my
chest hits so the pike is like this and
then it's like that right so when I when
I go I hit this end slide through it and
my and I fly forward and my chest hits
that so it [__] hits my chest and
during that whole time everything is so
slow motion and I'm like where am I
going
and I can't move my body fast in life
like what am I doing I'm like [__]
[__] like I have enough time to think
about everything and it's like you know
how Deadpool slows down and [__] like
and then you can think of all those
things it's just all those things happen
and I'm just like boom you're like
Quicksilver
dude this is why I hate outdoor exercise
you could die yeah it's too many
variables this is why I stay at home and
watch anime any outdoor exercises okay
so recently I tried skiing okay right
you got snowboard right it's skiing
snowboard that's that's an outdoor
activity right Outdoors yeah and so I'm
all right like I'm giving it a shot and
so first they take me up to this like
big slope I didn't know how high this
mountain was gonna be right and it just
keeps on going and going and going so
now I'm at the top and we're in Lake
Tahoe or South Tahoe up north okay right
and it was like the real mountain yeah
and this was during like the the
snowstorm that just happened
so so I'm looking up it's I just see
just whiteness just pure white so
hey
so I start I I start skiing right and
naturally it just I I just couldn't
break
because it was it was just snowing so
heavy and I just couldn't I couldn't
break so so when I was doing the pizza
all right no one taught you or anything
no no no I was watching some videos but
you know like let's just do bunny slope
well see my all my friends wanted to go
to the top so I'll go to the top I'm not
a [__] I'll go right and then and then
then when I tried breaking it wouldn't
break that's when I started tumbling oh
yeah and then I just couldn't like go
down without just tumbling we had a bad
time so not the only way you got back
down is tumbling down well at a certain
point I I had to I like I gave up you
took off the skis and you walked down I
took out the skis and I just laid there
for a second yeah you like tied the
boots hang them over your shoulder walk
of [__]
you kind of have to yeah
I didn't even start walking I just laid
there just just pray to God like someone
was gonna say but I told my friend I
hope a shark comes up
yeah
yeah I am but yeah I just saw my friends
hey just go down and get the paramedics
for me yeah imma just yeah yeah so they
got you out of there yeah yeah yeah yeah
they got me out huh you didn't have a
helmet I had all the gear I was so ready
I was so ready it's tough bro no I mean
for not knowing how to ski very well and
going to the top like that that's cool
they might have been setting you up to
die bro it's a lot
[Music]
thank you